es ist einem hoch mobile armee die 1939
über polen herfällt das oberste ziel der
deutschen strategie lautet so rasch und
so vernichtend wie möglich soll der
polnische gegner geschlagen werden
der deutsche angriff war sehr geballt
und er kam sehr schnell auch durch die
in den hohen grad der motorisierung
wehrmacht also der vormarsch ging so
schnell vonstatten dass die versorgungs
truppen der wehrmacht teilweise gar
nicht mehr hinterher kam von drei seiten
aus greifen die deutschen verbände an
bereits am nächsten tag durchbrechen sie
an mehreren stellen die polnischen
verteidigungslinien um ihr ziel
möglichst schnell zu erreichen sind den
invasoren alle mittel recht
ohne pause fliegt die deutsche luftwaffe
eine angriffswelle nach der nächsten
auch gegen ziele hinter der front später
berichten viele deutsche piloten wie sie
polnische kolonnen attackierten
militärische und zivile koppl scheinen
die männer dabei nicht gehabt zu haben
die deutschen truppen führer hatten den
befehl bei ihrem angriff auch terror
gegen die polnische bevölkerung
auszuüben damit demoralisierten die
deutschen die polnische armee und
erschwerten ihre mobilisation im
hinterland
[Musik]
der angriff der wehrmacht in polen geht
auch nach den ersten tagen unvermindert
weiter widerstand wird rücksichtslos
gebrochen
bei den kämpfen kamen auch viele
zivilisten ums leben darunter alte
menschen frauen und kinder eine kultur
des gehorsams tief in der deutschen
mentalität verankert sorgt dafür dass
fast niemand von der verbrecherischen
norm abweicht verstärkt wird sie durch
das leitbild der kameradschaft dem
ns-staat rassistisch begründet und
mythisch verklärt ist in der
kameradschaft sehen viele soldaten ihre
männlichkeit gewahrt
für manche wird die einheit zum
familienersatz
in der sogenannten kämpfenden
volksgemeinschaft ist die kameradschaft
der kitt der die wehrmacht auf allen
kriegsschauplätzen zusammenhält
krieg führen ist immer ein kollektives
unterfangen bei dem der einzelne
entscheidungsbefugnisse abgibt und in
kriegerischen situationen wird da genau
dieses verhaltens module menschen
aktiviert also man schaut sich um die
flagge wie es so schön heißt und denkt
dann nur noch im kollektiv und schützt
vor allen dingen die einst die die
eigene kameraden der feind ist einem
ziemlich egal den gilt es umzubringen
das ist so eine psychologische dynamik
die man in allen kriegen dieser welt
beobachten kann
während in den eroberten gebieten damit
begonnen wird durch terror und gewalt
die nationalsozialistische neuordnung zu
errichten setzt die wehrmacht ihre
offensive unter einsatz aller kräfte
fort keine drei wochen nach beginn der
kampfhandlungen sind die polnischen
streitkräfte fast überall besiegt nur
warschau verteidigt sich noch gegen die
deutsche übermacht
[Musik]
mit allem was er zur verfügung steht
greift die luftwaffe die polnische
hauptstadt warschau ist die erste
metropole der menschheitsgeschichte die
aus der luft zerstört wird
eine unterscheidung zwischen soldaten
und zivilisten findet auch hier nicht
mehr statt
mit der kapitulation warschaus geht der
polenfeldzug seinem ende zu 25.000
zivilisten kamen bei den kämpfen um die
stadt ums leben
die frage nach den opfern der deutschen
luftangriffe ist wichtig es handelte
sich zwar um eine militärische aktion
aber sie wurde oft gezielt gegen die
zivilbevölkerung gerichtet um sie zu
terrorisieren
diese bombardierungen opfer waren keine
kollateralschäden bei der bekämpfung
militärischer ziele sondern sie wurden
absichtlich getötet um die polnische
moral zu brechen
anfang oktober 1939 ist der krieg und
polen beendet die wehrmacht hat an allen
fronten gesiegt
die polnische armee ist zerschlagen die
regierung ist geflohen
warschau liegt in trümmern
die sieger lassen es sich nicht nehmen
ihren triumph in der hauptstadt des
feindes zu feiern gibt klar ist einen
großen schritt weiter und seine pläne
für den lebensraum im osten in die tat
umzusetzen
bis jahresende ermorden deutsche
polizisten und soldaten etwa 60.000
menschen in polen darunter 7000 juden